quelques pas suffisent au centre-ville
pour tomber sur un groupe de cônes
incongru on fait un tout petit trou sur
le trottoir et on a presque une centaine
de qu'on arrange qui se multiplient tout
partout c'est extrêmement envahissant
souvent pour des raisons qui
s'expliquent très mal un cadre
réglementaire qui est pas du tout sa
raison d'être c'est entre autres pour
essayer de changer ça que Montréal
organise un sommet sur les chantiers si
je vous dis l'offre 75% des chancistes
pour la Ville de Montréal moi je le
compresseur ça me dérange pas c'est qui
moi je veux je veux être capable de
circuler puis je veux que ça soit en
ordre
une escouade mobilité existe déjà depuis
2018 une quinzaine d'inspecteurs qui ont
effectué l'année dernière plus de 23000
interventions et ont remis près de 6000
constats d'infraction donc un tiers pour
obstruction des voies de circulation de
500 pièces quand même malgré tout il
s'accale un petit peu les entrepreneurs
mais cette expert n'est pas convaincu
que ce soit assez pour changer la
culture pour la plupart des
constructeurs ça rentre dans les coups
il défraie ça sans trop de problèmes et
donc il faudrait que il y a non
seulement des impacts de pénalisation
financière mais peut-être des impacts
sur l'octroi de contrats futures
d'interdiction peut-être d'opérer sur
Montréal si on a plus que deux ou trois
infractions
l'autre priorité c'est de mieux
répertorier l'ensemble des chantiers et
de rendre ces données facilement
accessibles il faut vraiment que les
gens réfléchissent davantage avant
d'amorcer un déplacement et pour ça faut
que l'information soit disponible pour
ceux qui planifient les réseaux que pour
ceux qui planifient ce déplacer Montréal
veut se présenter en mode solution à ce
sommet et a déjà fait des propositions
au ministère des Transports comme revoir
la taille des cônes la ministre guilbo
dit vouloir agir avant l'été pour rendre
les rues de la métropole plus fluides
ici Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal